DID NOT HAVE TO SEEK THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR UNDER STATE LAW.
ON TOP OF THAT, TODAY CHICAGO
MAYOR RAHM EMANUEL SENT SMOLLET
A LETTER DEMANDING HE PAY THE
CITY $130,000.
BY THE WAY, NEXT WEEK, TO HELP
COVER THE COST OF THE POLICE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE FAKE
ATTACK.
>> MY RECOMMENDATION IS WHEN HE
WRITES A CHECK IN THE MEMO
SECTION HE CAN PUT THE WORDS,
I'M ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE HOAX.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
MARTIN FRIEDE, VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE CHICAGO FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE.
ALL RIGHT, $130,000.
THAT IS RAHM'S BILL TO JUSSIE.
>> THAT'S NOT ENOUGH, WE
WOULD'VE BEEN BETTER IF THE
MAYOR JOINED IN CALLING FOR THE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION.
WE REALLY FEEL STRONGLY HE
SHOULD'VE DONE THAT.
HE DEMANDED A FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
HE ADVOCATED FOR A CONSENT TO
DECREE.
WE THINK IT'S UNJUSTIFIED THAT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
JEFF SESSIONS THOUGHT WAS
UNJUSTIFIED.
SO WE DEFINITELY THINK THAT THIS
IS WORTHY OF AN FBI
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY WHAT
YOU ARE REFERRING TO AS WHAT
MAYOR EMANUEL SAID TODAY ABOUT
BASICALLY TELLING TRUMP TO OUT.
>> MY RECOMMENDATION IS TO THE
PRESIDENT, GOOD OPENING DAY
BASEBALL.
STAY OUT OF THIS.
YOU CREATED A TOXIC ENVIRONMENT.
>> Laura: ALMOST LIKE HE HAD
TO GET BACK IN THE GOOD GRACES
OF THE LEFT AFTER HIS
PERFORMANCE THE DAY BEFORE WHERE
HE ACTUALLY FOUND IT REASONABLE
AND REALLY SMART ON THIS ISSUE
AND IS BACK TO HATING TRUMP
BECAUSE THIS HATE CRIME WAS REAL
BECAUSE THIS HATE CRIME WAS REAY
CREATED BY TRUMP AND THAT'S WHAT
HE'S IMPLICIT IN SAYING THEY
ARE, MARTIN.
>> WELL, I MEAN, YOU SAID THAT,
YES, AND I'M NOT GOING TO
DISAGREE WITH YOU.
AND LIKE I SAID, WHEN THE OBAMA
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WAS RUNNING
THINGS, HE WAS ALL IN FAVOR OF
THEM COMING INTO CHICAGO,
INITIATING INVESTIGATIONS THAT
WE DIDN'T THINK WAS JUSTIFIED
BASED UPON FALSE ASSUMPTIONS.
HE  IT WAS A LUDICROUS
INVESTIGATION.
TRUMP DOJ SAID NO, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO PUT IN A CONSENT
DEGREE, BUT HE AND THE STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL PUT IT IN.
HE DOES NOT WANT THE TRUMP DOJ
TO INVESTIGATE.
WHAT CLEARLY -- SOMETHING THAT
CRIES OUT FOR THE INVESTIGATION,
WHAT HAPPENED HERE?
WHAT WAS THE MOTIVE OF THINGS?
>> Laura: THIS IS ONE OF THE
MORE UNREAL THINGS THAT I EVER
WITNESSED WHEN IT COMES TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN THE COUNTRY
AND I'VE BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME
REPORTING ON ALL OF THIS.
MARTIN, I WANT TO GET YOUR
RESPONSE TO THE OUTRAGEOUS
ALLEGATION BY SMOLLET'S
ATTORNEYS.
SHE HAS A WILD NEW THEORY ABOUT
WHY THOSE TWO NIGERIAN BROTHERS
WERE IMPLICATED IN THE ATTACK.
>> OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN PUT MAKEUP
ON.
THERE IS ACTUALLY INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH A VIDEO.
I THINK POLICE DID MINIMAL
INVESTIGATION IN THIS CASE.
IT TOOK ME ALL OF FIVE MINUTES
TO GOOGLE -- I WAS LOOKING UP
THE BROTHERS AND ONE OF THE
FIRST VIDEOS THAT SHOWED UP WAS
ONE OF THE BROTHERS IN WHITEFACE
DOING THE JOKER MONOLOGUE WITH
WHITE MAKEUP ON.
IT'S NOT SO IMPLAUSIBLE.
>> Laura: MARTIN, DOES SHE
REALLY THINK YOU ALL, THE
CHICAGO PD, ARE THAT DUMB?
THE NIGERIAN BROTHERS WERE IN
WHITEFACE?
THAT'S THE NEW THING THEY ARE
GOING WITH?
>> WELL, DOES SHE REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE CHICAGO PD?
I MEAN, THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
IS GETTING A VIEW INTO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
CHICAGO, BUT IF YOU ARE A
CHICAGO POLICE OFFICER, THESE
KINDS OF WILD, OUTRAGEOUS THINGS
HAPPEN ALL THE TIME.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE BEEN READING
ABOUT KIM FOXX FOR A LONG TIME
ON CASES THAT I THINK ARE MUCH
MORE SCANDALOUS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE EXONERATION OF
CONVICTED KILLERS, ONES WE JUST
THINK ARE TOTALLY PLACE
BASELESS
ARGUMENTS EARLY MULTIMILLION
DOLLAR LAWSUITS AGAINST THE
DETECTIVES WHO INVESTIGATED THE
CASE.
IMAGINE BEING A DETECTIVE IN
THIS CASE.
YOU PAINSTAKINGLY INVESTIGATED A
HATE CRIME AND NOW THEY ARE
TURNING -- THEY ARE RIDICULING
YOU, THEY ARE MAKING A
LAUGHINGSTOCK OUT OF THE POLICE
OFFICERS.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, IT'S
BEYOND OUTRAGEOUS.
BUT SHE HAS AN ANTIPOLICE
MENTALITY DEEP IN HER BONES,
ANTIPOLICE.
I AGREE WITH YOU ON THE OBAMA
CONSENT TO DECREE, HANDCUFF
POLICE OFFICERS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
BY THE WAY, EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW
THIS, ON MONDAY -- WILL BE
COVERING IT ON MONDAY, THERE
IS GOING TO BE A BIG POLICE
PROTEST.
THE POLICE UNION IS GOING TO
HAVE A PROTEST AGAINST KIM FOXX.
YOU SEE THE DETAILS, 69 WEST
WASHINGTON.
IT'S GOING TO BE AT 11 IN THE
MORNING.
APRIL FOOLS' DAY, BUT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE A JOKE.
YOU ARE GOING TO GET A BIG
TURNOUT THERE, MARTIN?
>> WE THINK SO.
THE MEMBERS ARE OUTRAGED ABOUT
THIS CASE AND THEY ARE FINALLY
HAPPY THAT THE NATIONAL MEDIA IS
LOOKING AT IT.
YOU KNOW, CHICAGO IS CRYING OUT
FOR SOME REALLY GOOD
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM.
IT REALLY IS.